well the world as you've heard is going
to end in 12 years if not sooner unless
you immediately ditch your car and start
eating insects that's what the
presidential candidates and the
Democratic Party are telling us they're
very concerned but not so concerned that
they won't stop flying private so we've
got an idea for them we're calling it
the 2020 tree challenge and it's an idea
that will help compensate for the
greenhouse gases they are spewing into
the atmosphere every time they get in
their little Learjets plant a tree for
every mile you fly private such as a
challenge it's really a request slash
demand plant a tree for every mile you
fly private it's not hard and if you
care you will meteorologist Joe Bastardi
is the author of the climate Chronicles
the inconvenient revelations you won't
hear from Al Gore and others and he
joins us tonight
Joe thank so much going on so so even
those of us who were skeptical of the
details of some of climate theory and a
lot of his theory can get behind the
idea of planting trees I mean there's no
downside to planting trees so why
wouldn't these can enough take us up on
our tree challenge well not only that
but nuclear power there's a people that
think the combination of nuclear power
and planning enough trees let's say
across the entire world is the size of
Canada would offset the carbon dioxide
production by mankind and the question
is why wouldn't you try that it's much
less expensive both ways for one there
must be some other reason though and you
know there are times when I look at this
well you we both know what we believe it
is but I don't think they want this to
go away I think there's only one answer
that they want and this is a new Green
Deal we could all get behind let's plant
more trees right I clean and by the way
it's it's fascinating watching this
because you know plants grow best at
about 1,500 parts per million of carbon
dioxide and we're currently at about 410
parts per million of carbon dioxide
there is a natural synergism between
animal life and plant life
someplace in between because animals
exhale a hundred times more carbon
dioxide than they inhale that's right
you're a carbon pollutant organism you
are that's what you are
please help that they get that Nick yes
they get that and they grow in fact
Tucker it's getting dangerous out there
I have trees trying to hug me so because
they know human beings well they don't
know that but the fact is that the
planet is now greener than it's ever
been in the satellite era circling back
real quick here
the doctor will hopper this is exactly
the point he was making we're pulling
out of a co2 drought that the the
climate Optimum's the best time for life
on the planet is when a little bit
warmer and there's more co2 in the air
and that's just been established through
the geological history so yes why why do
we go why we go and spend ten trillion
dollars to save point
oh well Celsius over 30 years well we
can try this there is no downside to
planting redwoods and eastern white
pines that is it's all good of course it
doesn't increase their power so I doubt
therefore but we're gonna keep pressing
on our tree challenge Joe thanks so much
for coming on tonight thank you for
having me I'm gonna plant a tree as soon
as I get home tonight how's that man
good for you